Jennifer Lopez yes she could especially
with those abs we were with her last
night in New York and it is almost
impossible to believe she is turning 50
next month five ochem she's wrecking 50
for everyone yes she certainly is in her
life keeps getting bigger and better
with age and that's why she's on the
verge of completely losing it in a good
way I said I was gonna cry well should
we hear from you I'm thinking a lot
about life I'm going on tour for my
birthday it's a big birthday for me and
the 20 year anniversary of on the 6 and
the beginning of my music career like
it's a lot of things kind of converging
at this moment for me throughout JLo's
two decades of entertainment domination
the only thing that hasn't changed her
iconic style
[Music]
Jennifer accepted the style icon award
last night at the CFDA Fashion Awards
she flaunted those abs in an absolutely
perfect look by fellow Bronx natives
Ralph Lauren we understand the girls
love crop tops ponytails but what does
JLo say is her most iconic look of all
time of all time I'd have to see the
green Versace dress nasty matt mattox I
think that's the one that kind of goes
down in history backstage a rod was
careful to step around that train for
days she told us their daughters are
already calling dibs on her Hall of Fame
looks Ella called me she was like I want
your Grammy dress with the orchid right
here
it means like what about that mami are
we gonna keep that you're gonna don't
throw that out and yeah they tell me all
the time
[Music]